sony sony sony sony sony a éperonné par
l'un des amis les bras ça va vous allez
bien tout va bien j'espère moi ça va
très bien et je suis très heureux de
retrouver pour une séance de rattrapage
vous le savez j'ai été un peu pris ces
derniers mois dans un mois et demi je
crois que c'est pas de bêtises en
tournage avec amazon pour l'émission ça
va cartonner mais je suis de retour je
suis là et je rattrape mon retard
aujourd'hui je vous parle de ce casque
aulas le solide le h messe à leucate qui
succède à celui la leçon w/h 1103 qui
succédait lui aussi non j'ai pas lu 6 m2
offert la complète je vais donc vous
parler aujourd'hui de suivre le mx 5 4
ça fait quelques bonnes semaines que
j'ai sur les oreilles et ils
m'accompagnent est absolument partout en
déplacement en train en avion en voiture
et même pendant les tournages quand je
voulais parler à personne je l'avais
sont les oreilles c'est très pratique et
je connais aussi très bien le meilleur
endroit que j'ai depuis très longtemps
également dont je vous parlais de ce
modèle là je veux parler par rapport à
celui là
et croyez moi il ya plein de choses à
dire parce que le 1104 est vraiment très
très cool mais une blixen 4 d'enceinte à
côté des soins un petit peu vous
explique tout en fait et pour être
extrêmement précis j'ai vu un vrai cap
une révolution entre le mix n 2 de sony
et le mix n 3 quand on arrive sur 1100
rôle du roi où ce cas ce que là il
envoie vraiment du bois et il emmène
l'expérience audio sony avec la
réduction brute avec une qualité audio
au sommet est beaucoup plus haut c'était
vraiment très impressionnant et c'était
vraiment chouette
donc quand sony annoncés sont de me yaï
mixel 4 je me suis dit je pense que
beaucoup de monde se dit ouah c'est
génial on va aller encore plus loin en
termes de réduction de coûts en termes
de qualité audio on va un peu plus loin
mais on va guère plus loin et c'est un
petit peu ce qu'ils aiment frustré mais
malgré tout j'aime beaucoup ça il faut
le préciser
vraiment beaucoup parce que oui est ce
que là c'est un peu comme celui sur le
1000 x m3 on avait des haut parleurs de
40 mm ici faisait bien droite ce sont
exactement les mêmes c'est exactement la
même chose sur le 1000 x m3 on avait le
processeur le cul n 1 pour la réduction
de bruit sur le 1005ha tracé exactement
la même chose
le design du mix m3 c'est ce design là
et je veux pas vous mentir si vous
regardez le 1000 x n 4 c'est exactement
la même chose
la qualité audio du 1000 x m3 qui était
vraiment aussi une des références et
bien sûr le mythique salle 4
c'est sensiblement la même chose la
réduction
de bruit c'est une fois de plus et grâce
au processeur hdq n 1 et bien c'est
quasiment la même chose les kodaks du
mix m3 on a dû elle d assez de sony on a
du sbc
on a dû a assez et on a également de la
ptx et de la péter x hd de qualcomm
tandis qu'ici on va retrouver le ld
assez le sbc le ac et et banon le reste
on ne l'a pas on a donc une perte tout
simplement parce qu'effectivement sony
là dessus ne travaille pas avec qualcomm
bon ok ok ok ok ok c'était pas très
sympa de vous dire ça comme ça mais
c'est vrai il ya quand même c'est
différent cela beaucoup de points
similaires alors effectivement doublé h
musique 5 4 milliards il a aussi des
choses en plus et heureusement mais pour
l'instant être on voit c'est qu'il
ressemble quasiment trait pour trait ou
de mener h
melix l3 alors qu'est ce que ce bel xl
cap va avoir de plus que les milices am3
et bien c'est du pain de détails vous
allez vous en rendre compte
non pas du tout il a des coussinets qui
sont est légèrement plus épais mais
vraiment légèrement très légèrement ce
qui fait qu'en terme de confort on est
toujours très bien déjà la musique
samedi 3 lorsque vous le mettiez
l'impression de mettre des petits
chaussons sur la tête des petites
pantoufles tellement confort était
vraiment vraiment très très agréable
bien ici c'est toujours la même chose
vraiment un très très bon confort d'un
mètre sur notre tête on peut ressentir
un petit point de pression lorsque vous
tenez sur le thème depuis un bon petit
moment
ce que je conseille de faire s'il vient
d'ouvrir un petit peu plus vos oreilles
vont venir le calais il va pas puissant
votre tête et là vous aurez meilleur
confort que ce soit sur le mix à 4 ou si
on le met 6 m3 la nouveauté se situe ici
dans la rigole ce au niveau du capteur
de proximité
parce que lorsque vous allez retirer
votre caste et bien la musique va
s'arrêter à voilà une nouveauté qui
assez maligne c'est très très cool parce
que lorsque vous avez votre casque
serait-elle comme ça et que vous décidez
de l'ordre mais parce que vous voyez
quelqu'un vous voulez parler je sais pas
quoi te le contrôleur du train qui a
vérifié mobilier et bien sa coupe la
musique ça coûte votre série bones film
tout ce que vous regardez ça la réponse
assez bien et ça vous ne l'aviez pas
avant donc là on a un vrai bénéfice
autre nouveauté et moi qui m'emballe un
petit peu moins c'est lorsque vous
écoutez la musique la reconnaissance de
votre bras ce qui s'appelle le speak to
chat vous êtes comme ça que vous écoutez
de la musique et d'un coup vous mais tu
as parlé vous voyez quelqu'un à mon jour
je voudrais savoir comment tu vas et
bien qu est ce qui va se passer ça va
arrêter la musique ça va vous mettre le
son ambiant vous allez entendre une fois
ce tour ne vaut pour pouvoir échanger
que cette personne alors ça c'est très
pratique parce qu'effectivement on va se
dire super comme ça je peux avoir une
conversation mais je sais pas dans vos
co dabou mais pour moi ça paraît pas
très poli d'abord le casque et ne parle
à quelqu'un en même temps je trouve à la
au niveau social c'est pas
extraordinaire
il ya peut-être un sens peut-être
quelque part dans le blog n'est en tout
cas moi ici en france ça me dérange un
peu et je n'apprécierais pas quelqu'un
vienne me parler avec les casques sur
les oreilles
je trouve ça un peu bizarre maintenant
entre au point que je trouve un peu
négatif avec ça c'est que lorsque vous
écoutez de la musique et que vous
chanter une petite chanson paf s'arrête
votre casse va penser vous parlez à
quelqu'un qui ne pense pas il va en tout
cas être interprété comme ça n'a pas dû
perdre technologique sanaa m la pause et
ça je trouve ça un peu dommage c'est une
nouveauté mais je ne trouve pas génial
génial ce que j'aime bien sûr ce cas ce
cas c'est l'autonomie si on a une
autonomie de 30 heures alors printemps à
quelque chose près vouloir charger en
trois heures et en dix minutes de charge
des parties pour 5 heures d'écouté
autant dire que là franchement on vous
êtes quoi faire ça c'est très très très
bien la qualité est aussi plutôt bonne
au niveau de vos appels téléphoniques
pour utiliser votre casque pour passer
un petit coup de fil moi je devais déjà
avec le men x men 3 l'effet clinique
sainte 4 dans les deux cas ça
fonctionnera bien et jochen goller de ce
côté là non vous êtes bien évidemment
votre assistant vocal que ce soit google
assistant que ce soit amazon alexin de
la qualité audio est vraiment très très
bonne
moi j'ai pas ressenti vraiment de
différence y'a rien qui m'a surpris en
passant du mythique salle 3000 xm 4 je
m'attendais à avoir une surprise que ce
soit au niveau de la réduction de bruit
que ce soit au niveau la qualité audio
est pas du tout absolument pas vous
pouvez venir vous moduler deux
directement depuis votre application en
en modules et un peu les graves les
aigus les médiums pour venir faire leur
glace comme vous le souhaitez grâce à
l'équateur personnalisé donc ça c'est
vraiment très très bien ça l'était déjà
avant ça l'est toujours aujourd'hui donc
vous pouvez une fois de plus venir
paramétrer personnaliser l'expérience on
est pour moi sur la même expérience
sonore peut-être son tout petit point de
détail mais il faut vraiment venir le
chercher les aigus sont très beaux et
précis on a du graff qui est présent on
a une belle homogénéité au niveau des
bandes de fréquences bon pour moi ce cas
ce que là il fait très très bien tav
comme le faisait le mix m3 dont ne rien
de bien neuf ici non plus et comme je le
disais la réduction brute pour moi était
déjà
très bonne avec le minix m3 elle est
plutôt si bonne avec le 1000 x l4g pas
senti de différence pour moi 80 euros
d'écart entre deux produits
voyez alors s'il ya vraiment quelque
chose qui est tout nouveau et qui vient
d'arriver qu'on l'attendait sur le x men
3 qui arrive enfin sur le xo 4
eh bien c'est la collection multipoint
en bluetooth vous pouvez donc venir
connecter votre caste à différents
appareils vous peut connecter par
exemple à votre smartphone et en même
temps à votre ordinateur
ça peut être pratique lorsque vous
écoutez de la musique ou regarder un
film vous passez sur votre ordinateur et
vous avez un coup de fil sur votre
smartphone pour pouvoir décrocher mais
au-delà de ça bompas grande grande
différence à savoir que en plus et bien
dans la mesure où vous allez faire ce
multi points vous ne pourrez pas avoir
de l des as est elle forcément peut pas
tout avoir une empreinte de bande
passante un moment ou un autre il ya une
nouveauté aussi au point de vue logiciel
c'est le contrôle de son adaptatif et ça
je suis pas très fan je me sens bien que
je n'aime pas du tout alors j'aime
beaucoup ses casquettes vraiment je dise
je les aime beaucoup
sauf qu'à pas une grosse différence
entre lui et l'ex n 4 duval chine xm3
donner ma conclusion en quelques
instants mais le contrôle du son d'un
tati viennent pas trop je vous explique
pourquoi
vous êtes par exemple dans la rue vous
marchez selon vos réglages selon nous à
les paramétrer ou pas vraiment c'est ce
que j'ai fait ça va venir augmenter le
son extérieur pour je me rende compte de
ce cas autour de moi qui sont tendres ce
soit un vélo une voiture en us que je ne
fasse pas écraser donc promotion de
sécurité ça marche ça a un sens
maintenant par exemple je suis dans un
bus
eh bien il va le reconnaître que le bus
est en mouvement mais moi je ne suis pas
grand mouvement dont il n'a pas besoin
d'augmenter le son extérieur il va
activer la réduction de bruit mais
comment le bus va s'arrêter eh bien il
va considérer que je suis à l'arrêt et
plus en déplacement dans un transport en
commun il faut attendre un bip que je
trouve assez part dans le casque qui va
venir moduler la musique et ce moment là
ça me dérange
j'aurais préféré peut-être un bip
beaucoup plus discret un signal sonore
beaucoup plus discret beaucoup moins
intrusif dans ma musique
ça m'aurait paru beaucoup mieux ces
fonctionnalités je trouve bien mais une
fois de plus le signal sonore paraître
mal adapté parce que trop intrusif et ça
c'est un peu dommage
un des points forts du wmx m3 comme
doublure de lixheim 4 eh bien ça va être
son application
moi ici je suis connecté un iphone de ce
fait je n'ai pas dû à aider à cg
uniquement dû à ces vous voyez c'est
écrit ici mais j'ai un état complet se
connecte effectivement à deux iphone ici
au niveau du son qu'est ce que je vais
avoir comme l'information
eh bien j'ai mon contrôle de son ambiant
qui active et là sur la réduction de
bruit
le speak to chat personnellement je les
activer parce que ça ne plaît pas
particulièrement je peux avoir une
optimisation au niveau de la pression
atmosphérique lorsque je prends l'avion
sans me mettre à 0,8 à t elle ça
fonctionne surtout une partie qui pour
moi le plus intéressant c'est mon
équaliseur ici j'ai plusieurs
possibilités entre manuel discours j'ai
beaucoup de différents réglages celui
que je vais utiliser le plus eh bien ça
va être personnalisé je pourrais revenir
monter un petit peu ici mais aiguë en
termes de qualité sonore moi je vais
privilégier la qualité sonore à la
collection stable pour avoir le meilleur
qualité et j'ai pas activé ici mais je
peux venir l'activé si je souhaite le ds
le extreme qui va venir me rajouter de
la qualité audio amis sont compressés
ensuite systèmes connectés simultanément
à deux appareils
j'ai pas mal de petites options je peux
venir activer désactiver pour moi ça
marche très très bien et j'ai même en
boutons custom qui est juste là que je
peux venir personnalisés ici il est calé
sur amazon avec ça mais je peux le nier
a complètement le paramétrer autre chose
contrôle de son bouillant à 6 ans google
comme je veux c'est très pratique
soyons clairs très clair et très honnête
le wh1 ericsson 4 est un très bon casque
ce qui va avoir en plus par rapport de
la shdm xl 3 et bien ce capteur de
proximité pour venir mettre pause ou
plein lorsque vous allez l'enlever la
connexion bluetooth ou multi points au
lieu d'avoir un bouton n c ambiants d'un
bouton que stone sur nos machines x n 4
alors à la question faut-il acheter le f
mixel 4 ma réponse va être oui si vous
n'avez pas de casque de sony ou si vous
avez un casque anciens ça peut avoir un
sens dans la mesure où on voulait mettre
380 euros pour 3 179 en n 99 points très
précis si maintenant vous avez déjà un
double dash mlx am3 n'achetez pas le wh1
xm quatre salles a strictement aucun
intérêt si maintenant vous n'avez pas
380 euros et vous avez un petit peu
moins de 300 euros et bien acheté de
lever h
mais l'ex n 3 qui est un excellent
casque et qui pourra en tout cas reste
une référence
ce modèle la partie a soumis il va
repartir celui-là m'appartient je vais
le garder et je ne vais pas acheter de
biache nixon 4 même si j'ai bien aimé
pour moi la différence n'est pas notable
n'est pas significative
et il ya le soleil dans aucun intérêt à
changer mon 6ème 3 contre eux le mix n 4
a vous de me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire comment
vous le trouvez qu'est ce que vous en
pensez sa monnaie est sorti dit ça il ya
quelques petits mois je suis un peu en
retard je le sais je le sais je le sais
mais j'avais à coeur nous en parler
parce que j'ai tellement adoré ce modèle
là qu'ils soient semblait essentiel de
vous parler du mix n 4 dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
trouve extrêmement rapidement pour
continuer à parler tech parce que oui
oui oui et encore oui la sec ne s'arrête
pas il ya beaucoup de choses qui
arrivent pour lé soin de vous des bisous
ciao